taking the story forward
uh the months leading up to his
assassination what what uh
what do you understand why he was
assassinated
who were the players involved
maybe could you have stopped it
well i'll tell you after i saw reagan's
face on the
television saying we have the absolute
proof the phone rang
and it would bury i hadn't heard from
him in a couple years
he said i'm coming out tonight roger
and oh boy so uh
he came out he said i'll meet you in
this uh french restaurant i don't even
know in santa barbara
and i walked in there's about 20 or 30
people in there
and he was all 30 40 years old women
would
plastic or leather skirts and me and
their blue jeans and i looked around and
barry was at the back
he was leaned up he'd gain weight and i
walked up and i said barry you wired
he said no i said i'm not going to talk
are these dea agents
he said every one of them
[Laughter]
with jeans and skirts i like it
i said well barry i'm gonna set you and
you just talk to me buddy and tell me
what's on your mind
and he sat there and he just went to
talking and he told me about
he was left holding the bag and that um
what do you mean by that like that
nobody's supported him
or another he was uh and and i don't
know this i mean this is just what
what happened uh putting it all together
that he had some cia buddies
that was pretending we're going to
supply all of our northwood arms
and with that you can land cocaine back
here by the ton
so he's taking his little planes and
putting some ak-47s and
maybe ammunition or whatever and takes
it down to
the contras against the communist
party of nicaragua where we've been
landing and oliver north was involved in
this
so uh when the when all that and so his
cia buddies was certainly
involved and we know they were and barry
had been in the cia
earlier when he first got out of school
so uh
when uh as i say the [ __ ] hit the fan
they all fled and left barry hole in the
back the cia and the dea
yeah no not the dea the cia the dea
wasn't in on it cia was
was selling that cocaine bringing it in
and uh
just to clarify uh what's iran contra
scandal
what was the alleged involvement of the
cia
in uh in using drug trade to fund
things what do you know what do you
think is true
what should we know well i know what i
know is true
that barry was taking a small amount of
arms
back to central america and giving them
to whoever oliver north
group group were who oliver north was a
colonel that got
implemented and almost brought the
government down and so they said all
right
we're getting the guns from iran and
we're taking cocaine to pay for them
yeah and since congress won't give us
money to fight this war we're gonna
we're gonna circumvent it so that was
that was a whole thing so it was uh
cia's effort
to circumvent the funding mechanisms of
government
by selling drugs yes but it was a
handful of renegade cia agents it was
barry's friends
that was making a load load of money
tons of it come up if you would like to
read the book the
the big white lie the ci and the crack
cocaine epidemic
the cia put according to this uh
the book in michael levine i i didn't
remember his name last time i talked
uh wrote that book and he was a head ci
agent
he was a dea agent that exposed this
and the cia tried to kill him and he
says they put crack cocaine they
developed their
their chemists developed crack and they
put it in every country every city in
the united states on one weekend
so uh they were bringing it up by the
tons and that's for sure
and barry was bringing it can i ask you
a small tangent
question do you think
the public should trust the cia and the
dea
do you think they're mostly good people
that are
carrying out a good mission because this
kind of makes it sound like there's
renegade agents that are just
doing whatever the hell they want and
with uh
sometimes no regard for human life well
that's certainly true
but that's not everybody in there that's
just sometimes you get a few
policemen in the department that do
these things i
i don't believe i believe that our
government is is good
i think we got some fools running it
yeah i don't know how we get them there
but
i don't think i know okay so what was
barry's involvement here
so barry barry lean back in that chair
and he told me
that you know he'd uh he got caught with
one and a half tons and
he built it in uh the runway in
nicaragua
and uh had cameras
flashing inside and out and he flew it
back to homestead with
with an agent there and he brought the
agent over um
jake jacobson really nice fella i think
he was a crop duster
and we'd have got along we'd have been
on the right side and uh so we uh
we sat there and drank chevis regal
until i got pie-eyed
and uh barry told me about it he said
that he went to see edwin and me see
flew
he got out on bail and he flew his
learjet up to
washington and went in to see the
attorney general edwin meis
and they run him out of the office the
next day he went back said i have
absolute proof that the cia is bringing
tons of cocaine
are they running sons of cocaine into
the united states and edward
put him up with this agent jacobson i
believe it was
and they went down and got one and a
half tons and on the way back
they bellied it in and pablo escobar and
some of the other ones on general there
in nicaragua you can see them
toting it from one plane to the other
side in the book called the big
nose uh kings of cocaine it's got a
mention of me too
and also the other one has a mention of
me in it
says i'm in more files for the dea than
noriega
so who was wanted to get rid of barry is
that is
the who wanted to get rid of barry moore
the cartels
or the cia the cartel
but uh so barry leaned back and he and
he he told me the story
and the tears came down between his
fingers and he put his hands over his
eyes and he said
i i got you couldn't do it roger i just
couldn't do three life sentences
so i told him everything i went to
congress and i testified before congress
and he testified before congress for all
these things that he'd done
and he said i told him all about you but
you're under my
umbrella you got to testify with me
before grand jury in miami
and so the guy said you can come down
the de agent said you can come down
tomorrow with mari
first class or i'll take you down in
chains
and if you don't testify with barry the
only place you'll ever see your wife and
family again
is in a federal prison visiting room was
that a difficult conversation
oh looking into my eyes my guts was just
like ice water i can't testify against
my friends i just can't do it how am i
going to do it i just
i can't work with people and he was
honest with me how am i going to testify
against them
i can't spend the rest of my life in a
federal prison what on earth what a mess
barry you've got me into
so uh is that a kind of betrayal there
yes but it's still i wish it left me out
of it
i understand him getting his uh in such
a mess that he told
because if the cia and whoever else
would find him betrayed him
then he's going to tell everything if
you so i says all right i'll be to miami
so murray and i flew down
first class and i and i went to a lawyer
one of the biggest lawyers in miami and
i said man i am
in a mess this fellow's told everything
and i've got to say
something but i'm not a snitch man i
mean i can
help what can i do and he said well
being a snitch is like being pregnant
you either are you're not
[Laughter]
and he says i i don't represent snitches
but if you want to fight this case i'll
do it for 600
dollars and i boy my face turn red well
i'm not a snitch
he said well that's what you're talking
about he said let me tell you something
if you go in there and say one thing
and sign that paper and you don't tell
them everything you know
yeah then they will convict you of
everything you've ever done and you tell
them
so you can't do it so uh
i said barry i'm having trouble with a
lawyer give it i'll go tomorrow let's go
he said all right use my lawyer and he
gave me his card the lawyers card so
mari and i went to the festival
restaurant that night and barry and
debbie came in she was dressed pretty
and
barry was and so he's already about
finished so we had dessert together
and i said barry they're going to kill
you friend he said no they ain't going
to kill me so and so
such and such is gone and this another i
said barry they're gonna kill you man
they know
you can't deny it and uh you know i said
i didn't tell him i wasn't gonna testify
so i i hugged his neck
i really like and we fled to brazil i
took murray and the children went to
brazil
so you decided there you're not going to
find you and still i wasn't going to
i didn't know what i could do i'd talk
to a lawyer i mean i just didn't i
didn't know what what i could do but
the best in miami what he told me so i
had to go
and he went to brazil we went to did you
have a conversation with anybody at the
cartel
just i mean that's such an interesting
moment that tests the man's character
to not snitch and
did you have a conversation with anybody
no pablo with
you know about it like so it's just
understood i just didn't couldn't do it
but how many men like you are there
not many i had all my friends testified
against me i had 11 friends and every
one of them put their finger up roger
did it
and i was facing life continuing
criminal enterprise
still you couldn't do it i just couldn't
do it do you ever get respect
from the cartels for that from the uh oh
they would
tell the time i got back and stuff they
owe me money and i can't get it
so well that's about money i just mean
about human beings
oh i think so i've been back down there
and i've been welcomed
i i have my uh my contact and uh when i
was in brazil i was trying to get this
money they owe me three and a half
million dollars
so i called up there and he was gonna
pay me oh i got six hundred thousand
today and i'll get you some more
tomorrow and then the next week i called
hey hey guy great news great news barry
seal's been killed
so oh no when i went back to the hotel
we was up in the northern part of brazil
and where was it mighty uh yeah
and uh so i went back and i told mario
and miriam and
uh and they cried and i cried i really
cried how
how is that great news from the cartel
well now
there's no case against me and him and
them do you know who killed them
yes i'll tell you about that story
on the first load i did i landed in a at
a banana plantation
and it was raining and it was a muddy
strip clay
and they put the 300 kilos of cocaine
and then the ugliest man you can imagine
named ronaldo got in there with a mac
10. and uh
he would make sure i took it to
louisiana
so this is many years before yeah a
couple years before so anyway he uh
uh we took off and the mud
got up in the wheel well so so thick
until the wheels wouldn't come up
well i'm going 200 miles an hour instead
of 300 miles with wheels coming down
well i can't go back there if i do i'm
gonna be in the same situation until the
sun dries it out in a few days
and so but in belize i had a runway that
we've been used for ten thousand dollars
used to refuel
so i told the guy listen we got to land
in police
to refuel and no no no he put them back
10 and uh
i'll shoot you go ahead fool you're
going to die too so
yeah who's in the turf so he wasn't just
ugly he was also
he was a bad bad killer yeah so uh he's
the one to actually kill
barry the one that went up on the first
load with me
and uh ronaldo when he's in doing live
he's just a killer
yeah he's doing life in louisiana i
wonder who uh
is is it known who made that decision uh
the younger
uh ochoa brother i understand fabio
which one paid for the hit i don't know
that but that's what i've heard which
probably sounds about right he's
he's down in jessup georgia doing a long
long time i think he's about to get out
he's been in
30 years or whatever
you